GREENPEACE SOUP, THEY HAVE TO
SAY DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
REELECTED, 45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WE CAN ALWAYS
HOPE.
ONE THING HAS REMAINED THE SAME.
THE SHEER UTTER INCOMPETENCE,
THE COWARDICE OF LIBERAL
POLITICIANS THAT RUN ALL THESE
BIG STATES.
THEY’VE BEEN RUNNING THEM FOR
DECADES, AND AMERICAN CITIES,
ALL ACROSS THE GREAT COUNTRY.
IT IS NOW MORE OBVIOUS THAN EVER
HOW BAD THEY ARE.
WE’VE HAD TO FACE THIS YEAR THE
WORST GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND 100
YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP IS SIGNING TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST KNOWN CASE OF
CORONAVIRUS, A TRAVEL BAN AND A
QUARANTINE WHICH WE HAVEN’T HAD
IN 50 YEARS.
THE HARSH REALITIES NOW OF THIS
COUNTRY’S ECONOMY BEING SHUT
DOWN, WE HAVE BEEN FEELING IT.
WE HAD A GREAT NEWS, BUT A WEEK
FRIDAY AGO, NOT ONLY WERE THEY
OFF BUT THEY WERE OFF BY ABOUT
11 MILLION.
STATE GOVERNORS PROVIDED ZERO
SOLUTIONS DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
TOTALLY UNPREPARED AND TOTALLY
INCOMPETENT AND THEY TURN TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SAVE THEM.
THEY COULDN’T SAVE EVEN THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR SOCIETY, THE
ELDERLY AND NEW YORK DID IT,
NEW JERSEY DID IT, PENNSYLVANIA
GOVERNORS, THEY ALL DID IT, ALL
THESE GOVERNORS.
THEY ORDERED THE IS LONG-TERM
CARE FACILITIES AND NURSING
HOMES TO TAKE IN COVID-19
PATIENTS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN
LIVES COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED.
TWO INSULT TO INJURY, THEY ADDED
ALL THE HOSPITAL BILLS.
BUILT BY THE PRESIDENT AND
MANNED BY THE PRESIDENT,
CONVERTED TO COVID-19 CAPABILITY
AND CHANGING THE VENTILATORS.
THEY ALL CHANGED, ALL THE PPE
WAS GIVEN TO THEM BY
DONALD TRUMP.
IT SHOOK THIS COUNTRY IN
RESPONSE TO GEORGE FLOYD’S
DEATH.
THEY ALSO EXPERIENCE DEADLY
RIGHTS IN AMERICA’S MAJOR CITIES
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN CITY AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS.
THEY ARE TOTALLY UNPREPARED AND
TOTALLY INCOMPETENT THAT AGAIN.
WE SEE LOOTING, WE SEE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION, INNOCENT PEOPLE AND
OVER 20 HAVE DIED.
WE SEE PRECINCTS BURNED TO THE
GROUND IN THESE DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS HAVE DONE
NOTHING TO STOP THIS.
IN FACT MANY DEMOCRATS ARE
ACTUALLY SUPPORTING THE ANARCHY.
AND PICKETS AS BAD AS IT CAN GET
GET.
>> THEY HAD SNIPERS ON THE ROOF.
BURN IT TO THE GROUND, YOU KNOW.
I DON’T EVEN WANT TO SAY THAT,
BUT, THEY RUN CITIES AND STATES
INTO THE GROUND.
EVEN BEFORE THE RIOTS, VIOLENT
CRIME IS ALMOST ON EVERY MAJOR
CITY ON THE RISE IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN
FEELING FOR DECADES.
THEY NEVER DO A THING TO FIXATE,
TAXES ARE HIGHER THAN EVER AND
YOU SEE AT THE MASSIVE EXODUS
OUT OF ALL THE CITIES.
ONCE AGAIN, A BIG LIBERAL CITY
HAS COMPLETELY NOW LOST CONTROL
OF A CRITICAL SITUATION.
WHILE POLICE PRECINCTS BURNED,
AND IT’S SO BAD THAT A BIZARRE
GROUP OF THE IS A LOOSELY
AFFILIATED R&R CRESTS, THEY HAVE
LITERALLY NOW TAKEN OVER SIX
CITY BLOCKS.
UNDER SIEGE WITHOUT ANY POLICE
PROTECTION.
A POLICE PRECINCT IS NOW UNDER
ANARCHIST CONTROL.
GOVERNOR INSLEE, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
NOTHING UP TO THIS POINT.
BY THE WAY, PRESENT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN BEGGING ALL
OF THESE BIG CITIES.
I WILL SEND AND HELP BUT YOU
HAVE TO ASK FOR IT.
THEY WILL STEADFASTLY DO WHAT IS
RIGHT.
PROTECT PROPERTIES AND PROTECT
THE INNOCENT.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THESE
FAR LEFT RADICALS ARE ALSO DEAD
SHOCKINGLY, THEY ACTUALLY BUILT
THE BORDER WALL.
I GUESS WALLS WORK, IS THAT WHAT
THE MESSAGES HERE?
ARM TO AND VIGILANTE UP INTO AND
OUT OF THE SO-CALLED AUTONOMOUS
ZONE.
BUILDINGS INSIDE THE ZONE ARE
GETTING VANDALIZED AND BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE GETTING REPORTS THAT
THEY ARE BEING EXTORTED.
FIGHTS ARE BREAKING OUT, THEY
ARE BEING ASSAULTED AND AN
ENTIRE POLICE PRECINCTS TOTALLY
ABANDONED AND TAKEN OVER BY THE
ANARCHISTS.
SIX BLOCKS OF PURE ANARCHY
INSIDE OF THE GREAT
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
NOW I DON’T KNOW ABOUT YOU, I
DON’T THINK YOU IMAGINE WE WOULD
SEE ALL THIS IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY OF OURS.
THEY DIDN’T DO ANYTHING TO
PROTECT INNOCENT PEOPLE, EITHER.
ABC NEWS IS CALLING THIS A
LIVING NIGHTMARE BUT, GET THIS.
A FESTIVE ZONE.
ACCORDING TO ABC, "POLICE IN
SEATTLE HAVE LARGELY WITHDRAWN
FROM A NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE
PROTESTERS HAVE CREATED A
FESTIVAL LIKE SCENE THAT HAS
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP FUMING.
THE REAL PROBLEM FOR ANYONE WITH
EYES TO SEE AND A FUNCTIONING
BRAIN IS THAT SEATTLE’S
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR WASHINGTON’S
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR, THEY ARE
DOING NOTHING TO PROTECT THEIR
PEOPLE AND RESTORE ORDER.
PROTECTING LIFE, PROTECTING
PROPERTY.
THE CITIZENS OF SEATTLE ARE NOW
LITERALLY IN DANGER AND ARE
WATCHING IT IN REAL TIME.
THESE DEMOCRATIC SO-CALLED
LEADERS ARE DOING NOTHING TO
PROTECT THE CITIZENS OF STATE
AND THEIR CITY.
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY AS A GROUP
OF IDIOTS ANARCHISTS DESTROY
THEIR OWN CITY.
JUST LISTEN FOR EXAMPLE TO
SEATTLE’S ASSISTANT POLICE
CHIEF, THIS KIND OF SHOCKED ME
FROM EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> TO BE CLEAR WE DID NOT PULL A
POLICE OFFICER OUT OF THE AREA.
WE ARE STILL RESPONDING TO 911
CALLS AND LIFE SAFETY
EMERGENCIES.
WHAT WE DID WAS BOARD UP THE
WINDOWS OF THE BUILDING TO
ATTEMPT TO SECURE IT FROM ANY
INCENDIARY DEVICES BEING THROWN
THROUGH THE WINDOW OR ANYONE
MAKING AN INJURY IN SETTING A
FIRE.
>> Sean: IS TODAY THE
PRESIDENT RESPONDED TO THE CHAOS
IN SEATTLE DURING AN INTERVIEW
WITH OUR VERY OWN
HARRIS FAULKNER.
HERE’S WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
>> President Trump: IF THERE
WERE MORE TOUGHNESS YOU WOULDN’T
HAVE THE KIND OF DEVASTATION
THAT YOU HAD IN MINNEAPOLIS AND
IN SEATTLE.
YOU DON’T SEE WHAT’S GOING ON IN
SEATTLE COME IF THEY DON’T
STRETCH STRAIGHT IN THAT
SITUATION OUT, WE ARE.
>> Sean: NOW THE PROTESTERS IN
THE AUTONOMOUS ZONE ARE HOLDING